so we are going to continue through
induction today but particularly the
kind of induction we're going to do are
called first order
which
um is not a Star Wars reference and um
first order recursive formulas so before
we get into any of the induction stuff
we need to know what these things are
okay we'll come to first order in a
second this is the key word here
recursive do either of you do software
design by any chance you do okay yes
it's all right if you don't um because
I'm gonna I'm gonna assume sort of you
know we'll go from this but you might be
familiar with recursion already from
software design the whole idea is
something that's recursive is it's a
formula that kind of refers to itself
which is a little bit weird but you've
actually encountered these before so let
me give you the most famous recursive
formula that you've encountered before
I'm going to write it
and then I wonder if you can tell me
actually what it is and there are some
significant Clues here right so this is
the formula
before I explain kind of what it
actually gives us right the whole idea
here is there's some formula for
whatever capital F is but to define a
particular
the nth capital F you've got to know
what the previous one and the one before
that were so it's kind of like referring
to itself and that's this recursion idea
do you know what capital F is
it's the Fibonacci sequence right so in
order to work out you actually have to
define a couple of numbers to start with
and we generally start with one and one
and then you say well okay if I forgot
one and one then the next one is going
to be you add them together two then one
plus two equals three two plus three is
five and off you go right so there's
this idea here that you have to start
somewhere just to find some numbers and
by the way you don't have to Define them
as one and one you can start at two and
one and you get the Lucas sequence which
is actually really it's more interesting
than Fibonacci Sequence which is weird
because everyone knows about Fibonacci
no one knows who Lucas is anyway we can
get to that another time but the key
thing is it refers to itself okay I've
got a few other examples here ones that
you actually are also familiar with so
let's think about this one
now we know what the factorial sequence
is good morning how are you Michelle now
obviously we could say this as say for
example if I ask you what 5 factorial
was you would tell me it's
120 as a as a whole thing but how did
you calculate 120 where'd it come from
uh
right so you start from one and then you
keep just going up in integers
multiplying until you get to n right so
that is what we would call an explicit
formula it just kind of lays out the
entire thing but it's a way to describe
the factorial
in a more succinct way but it has to
refer to itself so we would say okay
just take that number
and then multiply it by the previous
factorial does that make sense now this
is it's more succinct but you've like
well in order to work out this one I had
to know the previous one however I can
say oh six factorial without going one
times two times three if I already know
what five factorial is like you just
told me I'm like okay it'll be six times
five factorial 720 off I go right okay
let me give you one more I've got one
more example here oh yeah fantastic
um however I'm not sure if you're up to
this one yeah you finished the whole
Advanced course but have you done series
and sequences yet
not yet that's fine that's okay I'm just
going to introduce this one for you so
for example
um if we were going to say
a
progression of numbers right and then
the numbers just go up by the same
difference every time so this is what we
call an arithmetic progression you'd say
okay to get to one term you would go
from the previous term and then you just
add whatever that common difference is
so for example the odd numbers one three
five seven nine right well you just go
from one term and then you just add 2
would be what gives you from one term to
the next but you actually don't have to
have a gap of two you could have a gap
of anything we just call that the common
difference okay so again the key thing
is and you can see it every time right n
minus 1 and minus one n minus one you're
looking backwards right so that's this
idea of recursion okay other color now
we can understand what this part means
first order okay these are all recursive
formulas here but two of them are first
order and the other one is not the whole
idea is how complicated is this is how
far do I have to go back okay so do you
notice for these two formulas right you
only have to go one step back
a minus one n minus one so for each of
these we would call them first order
because
you only need to know the previous one
term okay
the Fibonacci sequence though because
you have to go too back we would call
that
second order
so
thankfully for us
um excuse me the extension to syllabus
explicitly excludes these you actually
can work them out using in some ways
many of the same tools I'm going to
introduce to you for these but they're
just they're just more work because
they're second order okay so we're going
to stay in this territory down here now
the whole idea
is that
these are recursive formulas but if I
wanted an explicit formula then I would
need to prove that explicit formula
works these are kind of like the
definitions of each of them there is
actually for example an explicit formula
for the Fibonacci sequence but almost no
one encounters it because it's weird
it's it's strange because we know one
one two three five eight thirteen all of
the Fibonacci numbers are whole numbers
which makes sense because you just get
them by addition right however weirdly
the explicit formula for the Fibonacci
sequence it's got like
weird Suds in it it's got the golden
ratio it's very strange okay
um and you might think like where did
that even come from where do any of the
explicit formulas come from we can use
induction to prove them so as an example
say with this one here I'm gonna I'm
gonna put on you for this one right do
you know what the explicit formula is
for the nth term
of an AP
yeah very good now let's just even if
you haven't done this it's a simple idea
you start at some first number so we
said the odd numbers would start from
one usually and then you add some number
of the differences right so if I wanted
to get to the seventh odd number we
would start from one
and then we would add a lot of twos
because that's how you progress each
time from one odd number to the next so
if I said to get to the seventh one
you'd add
six lots of that common difference which
would be what is that that's six times
two which is twelve so we'd say oh there
you go there's the seventh odd number so
this is an explicit formula you can see
it doesn't rely on knowing the first
second third fourth fifth and sixth odd
numbers I can go straight there
but how do I actually prove that this is
the case and this is where induction
comes in okay so here's the way I'm
going to do this I'm going to give us
some examples of this but I'm going to
do something which you know how I said
this is not in the syllabus right I'm
going to show you a theme that's not in
the syllabus so don't freak out you're
like how am I going to have to do this
in an exam the first thing is something
you're not going to have to do in the
exam however hopefully I'll be able to
convince you persuade you why it's
actually worth having a look at this
morning okay